je m'appelle alexis fercak je suis
journaliste au figaro je m'appelle
luc-antoine le noir je suis journaliste
au figaro nous sommes allés au festival
youngtimer sur le circuit de montlhéry
dans l'essonne le new times un festival
c'est un rassemblement de centaines de
voitures des années 80 90 2000 c'est ce
qu'on appelle les young timers par
position old timers et qui se retrouvent
sur l'anneau de montlhéry c'est un
anneau de course automobile mythique est
venue notamment pour ça pour sa piste
incliné qui est assez ancien aujourd'hui
complètement cabossé donc on voit ces
voitures souvent pas du tout fait pour
la course qui l'empruntent en général
assez vite fait part de ce break nevada
à reno des années 80 avec le conducteur
et sa passagère qui étaient casqués
s'étaient assez étonnant de les voir
ainsi courir sur l'anneau de montlhéry
mais c'est avant tout un rendez vous de
passionnés
[Musique]
on est très loin de l'univers des
voitures de collection complètement
restauré avec des gens très riches là il
faut bien voir que la plupart des young
timers font des voitures qui coûtent
entre cinq et dix mille au maximum
quinze mille euros on a vu c'est que les
gens qui collectionnent ces voitures
sont essentiellement ceux qui ont grandi
avec ça peut être un jeune qui aimait la
voiture de son père ou de sa mère dans
laquelle ils voyageaient quand il était
petit avec laquelle il allait à l'école
par exemple et qu'il a eu envie
d'acheter à son tour une fois adulte
comme un souvenir ou bien ça peut aussi
être une voiture de sport une voiture de
luxe qu'il avait fait rêver quand il
était enfant et qu'il décide d'acheter
ce que je retiens particulièrement de
cet événement c'est l'immense diversité
des collectionneurs et de leur véhicule
vous avez quelqu'un dont la porsche 911
à plusieurs décennies et qui est
absolument comme neuve on a l'impression
qu'elle sort du sinn parce qu'elle est
extrêmement bien entretenu vous avez à
côté une bande d'amis dans une twingo
vert
qui est en train de pique-niquer vous
avez des gens qui collectionnent des
breaks avions des fourons donc c'est pas
uniquement des coupes et des voitures de
sport c'est vraiment tout ce que la
production automobile faisait à l'époque
et qui maintenant fait partie de
collections je vais retenir un
personnage qu'on a rencontré pierre
emmanuel sur deux mais pep il a une
grange à la campagne avec 24 voitures
des voitures assez hétéroclite un commis
dilemme les mal aimés là une renault
fuego il a une citroën c15 la
camionnette à vocation plus agricole une
rare talbot tagouraït là aussi ne
jacques gouin riggi v12 de la fin des
années 80 qui n'est pas une mal aimés
mais c'est une voiture qui tombent
toutes en panne qui fait en même temps
sourire il a mille histoires à raconter
sur ses voitures et les collectionne
depuis maintenant longtemps comme il dit
donc si vous voulez c'est un rêve de
gosse et c'est ce que je retiendrai dans
ce milieu des young timers c'est plein
de gens qui sont pas nostalgique qui
sont pas dans leur gré qui ne sont pas
en train de se dire qu'un
monde de l'endurance automobile est en
train de disparaître mais qui vivent
leur rêve au quotidien
de sa ressort une très très grande joie
c'est un démon sa grève
[Musique]